one of Bolton's teammates in the u.s.
anti Maduro squad is that the pressure
to back home from the families of
genocide survivors they've launched the
petition calling for the removal of
Elliott Abrams currently the US special
envoy to Venezuela from the board of the
Holocaust Memorial Museum in a letter to
the Holocaust Memorial Council and the
Committee on conscience they accuse
Abrams of supporting genocidal regimes
for decades they demand that his seat is
taken away one of the petition makers
and the daughter of a Nazi genocide
survivor told us why she's against
Abraham's it's a shame and disgrace that
people whose hands are in blood that can
be a member of a Holocaust Memorial
Council's Committee on conscience Abrams
has been convicted of withholding
evidence from Congress over covert
funding of Nicaraguan rebels back in the
1980s while he was serving the Reagan
administration is also been accused of
covering up massacres and backing brutal
regimes in Guatemala El Salvador and
Honduras Liliana Cordova Krasinski again
says Abraham's portfolio makes him
unsuitable as a member of the Holocaust
Memorial Council we want to demonstrate
to people who are the advisors of Donald
Trump and his criminal history and that
this person is preparing plans to invade
Venezuela and probably other countries
of Latin America or even the world we
hope that this petition will resonate in
an echo in those people who believe that
the Museum of Holocaust is an
untouchable topic my mom and the rest of
my family were slaughtered by Nazis
genocide my father was one of the
soldiers who defended Vilnius and then
he became a partisan and fought against
Nazis this regime is devoted to genocide
of Jews and such a criminal person as
Elliott Abrams should be removed from
the Committee on conscience now we have
requested a comment from the museum on
whether they are planning to take any
action in response to that petition
we'll let you know if we get a reply
you